[Music]
finally a bar with only women's sports
play
and it's totally empty
it's
completely empty
frozen can you find the article please
busy laughing
thinking about merchant i have talked
how many times have we talked when
you've been stuck at a sports bar and
the only thing on stuff you nba or like
a female problem yeah well female
college [ __ ] sometimes is good at least
it's volleyball basketball no if it's
like volleyball or like softball then
you're like all right you know some of
them [ __ ] are bad but no it's yeah
you always immediately go like
is there anything that dudes are doing
that you could put on yeah it's the
place is called
sport
sport i can't can you sports bra thank
you the sports bra i don't know why this
one tickles me so much because that's
not me no okay well fair enough
you know fun fact just like women
athletes this bar makes 10 percent of
what other sports bars make
but like we sit on the boys cast don't
worry men are closing that gap of crypto
real quick oh yeah real quick i found a
video
the sports bra is
a women's sports bar it's not a sports
bar for women but it's a bar for women's
sports so everyone is welcome
so and obviously they went when it was
big maybe it does get busy and that's
the thing about a bar
is that if you do have good food and
good drinks people are gonna go anyway
so maybe they do okay but if you notice
that place is not nobody's lined up to
try to get a good spot at the bar so
they could watch the [ __ ] the new
york liberty
so um i want
i want i want you to i want you to
notice something on the screen it's it's
a female basketball game nc will a women
i already know what you're going to say
it's the fourth quarter four's you go to
the fourth quarter four minutes left can
you tell me what the score is please
fourth quarter four minutes left in the
game
and south carolina is routing miami
36-23
this has happened to us by the way is
this way to are we sure this isn't a
soccer game
but hey check it out creighton
and ohio had a high scoring match this
is the high scoring match of 64 to 62.
this is these are football scores this
is ridiculous these are that is 36 to 23
is the football kansas city and green
bay score right
it was a shootout here in lambeau
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] ma'am
come here it's a couple letters that
switch around
i already said no
okay
okay by the way same name as the guy who
did uh james the win
korean this one this korean i know
they're korean yeah it's james nougat
jenny jenny nougat
jenny nugs
is he wait the korean or are they
vietnamese frozen vietnamese vietnamese
brown from sports by the way just for
reference
um last night was the mavericks versus
the suns
123 to 90.
wow what a [ __ ] difference though huh
um
game seven two dorothy pointed out in
the chat that the uh the sports prize
listed on google is uh permanently
closed no no this is from a month ago
how's that possible i don't know maybe
all the [ __ ] masks mandates no
there's no way are you serious hold on
hold on the
sports bra portland oregon
no recently opened oh recently opened
yeah it's closed uh today
and it's closed tomorrow
but it is open wednesday 11 a.m to 11
p.m
so i guess you don't want to watch any
like
any
west coast sports games apparently
uh because sometimes those go late uh
thursday so it's open uh
wednesday through sunday
11 a.m to 11 p.m from sports bar to
sports bra so it's very something very
familiar so i want people to walk in and
it feels like just your average regular
sports bar you know but then when you
take in what you're seeing there's
female athletes on the walls there's
female athletes on the tv screen yeah
cool can you do me a favor uh can you
put the tampa bay game on please thank
you yeah
the lightning might have a shot at the
cup this year can we watch real sports
please can you imagine you mentioned
them saying no can you imagine okay no
can you imagine going into
going into a sports bar like in town you
know the town you see sports bra you
think it's like a hooters because think
about it that you think it's like a
hooter's name like a twin peaks or
whatever sure so you go to sports bar
you're like oh man hey dude
nba finals tonight
let's go we sit down and they're just
playing old replays from w and the
liberty sparks or whatever
some some vietnamese dikey chick with
the tim pool hat he's like hey what's up
bro
hey can you put like a man game on
please yeah please can you like do you
understand that the lightning of a
chance at the start at the stanley cup
this year could we please put that
series on thank you there's like four
stanley cup playoffs happening right now
tonight can you maybe
and you know it's realistic it is a
sports bar for women there's only one tv
you have to keep lowering the volume and
she keeps standing in front of it with
your food
and it's those people
look at that skateboard very problematic
skateboard on her turf stay rad
girl skateboard
um
excuse me are you a biologist sports bra
i think make a huge difference
being a long-time sports fan being a
long-time lesbian
so this is just a lesbian bar
i guess
it seems like it right
both men's and women's it's amazing to
have no not both men's and women because
here's the thing men like watching men's
sports do you know what kind of sports
women like watching men's sports a bar
like this where it's just you don't have
to worry about fighting somebody oswald
was into sports i was going to say look
she looked like an old patton oswalt
yeah
or kevin james brother in king queens
yes
tv to find a your favorite playoff game
of you know march madness or whatever
this is going to be a wonderful by the
way ladies you do realize right this is
like
go ahead
you guys are like local shitty local
bands right
where you don't actually like
you're not actually good like nobody
actually wants to watch you do stuff
so you have to constantly have like
shirts and signs everywhere to support
women support women owned the businesses
make sure we're all supporting women
like you don't have to remind people to
get tickets when a good band comes to
town right but you always hear people go
hey we got to support local bands we got
to support local artists women you're
the social equivalent of local artists
or it's like hey man we need to go to
more local shows dude and it's like you
have to remind yourself too because
nobody wants to you have to force
yourselves to support one another
because even deep down ladies let's be
honest maybe some of you aren't into
sports but gun to your head somebody's
gonna make you watch sports you are not
watching women's sports let's be honest
so check this out merch i found their
website
they have a schedule of what's on this
week because of what games are on so you
want to go through it with with you okay
we're not going to do all of them
because there's too many but um let me
check out the schedule here what's
playing at the sports bra
literally nothing
literally nothing
well
you know wait hold on can i see
up there you go no hold on can i
apologize
geneva open huh women's tennis and then
wednesday if we're lucky we'll get the
rodeo the rodeo
is there a
ladies rodeo
oh here we go
yeah yeah yeah right ncaa let's go
division one baby who's playing not
gonna tell us
we don't know he's not gonna tell us
let's see what's going on in the month
and a month we're gonna get some big
games
the french open
you want to go to the sports ball sports
bra kick a couple back
i don't okay
community citizen arcane is a good idea
dave portnoy should open a bar across
the street
call the sport bros
the sports bro the sports bro exactly
and uh don't worry guys because we're
gonna have like pizza yeah we'll do
chili cheese dogs we're gonna have all
the best beer locally sourced and we're
gonna have sports betting put in there
and you're gonna go oh my god he's just
gonna destroy he's gonna kill him
so we partnered up with freelance
spirits which is okay and then the rest
of this woman's career is just gonna be
people walking in her dead restaurant
going hey is this the one dave portnoy
owns and she's like no it's someone
across the street
not a big fan of their menu
so we partnered up with freelance
spirits which is a women-owned and
operated distillery of course it is who
wants booze made by a woman give me
something on their menu frozen
uh do you want a beet salad
add us
no you said they said that it was gonna
be like a regular sports bar that it was
going to be like a regular [ __ ]
sports bar but they're women what else
frozen give me give me like a big a big
sports bar food that i could get like
some some comfort food what can i get
would you like a temp
tempeh reuben
which is a grilled marinated
marinated and grilled tempe which is
like tofu
layered with sauerkraut and vegan cheese
served on rye
just like a sports bar
just like a sports bar get a round of
vegan reuben's for the boys vegan also
for a side you can have it with roasted
brussels sprouts
oh that's way better than french fries
and onion rings way better oh yeah you
know when i go to mcdonald's i always
get it with the brussels sprouts you
know royce
frozen you know
i'm looking at the menu too and you
you're you're underselling it they do
have some good stuff here for instance
um
if you want a greek chichi bean salad
i was about to get to that one you know
like that's uh i don't know i don't want
that i've never wanted that do you guys
like that you'd have to probably go like
hey
do you guys like have a fryer back there
that we could put to use
do they have any fried food like
anything
that's worth a [ __ ] like something that
would be sports food like what's the
closest thing to a sports bar we don't
you don't you don't consider steamed
broccoli a sports no i don't i don't
want steam bro first off broccoli
broccoli should be illegal at a sports
bar
because you don't have that there you
can have broccoli at a steak please they
have fried cauliflower but even that
looks gross
and i like fried cauliflower if you do
it right you do buffalo cauliflower
pretty good yeah you do or broccoli is
another good one you can do fried deep
fruit but this is cauliflower dipped in
turmeric chickpea butter and fried
served with cilantro tahini sauce there
you go pulled pork it's just like a
regular sponge
why do you do this you're supposed to
just
do it egg and batter it like a chicken
cutlet and then you drop it in a fryer
until it's crispy
very simple fried fried vegetables it's
hard to do to get the batter to stick
but if you get it to stick and you know
what you're doing it's very simple make
yourself a better batter fry it
look you already have beer make yourself
a beer batter again i don't understand
this
i don't understand what the this is just
for lesbians right yeah this is here in
cortland mom's baby back ribs which is
uh half rack i love ribs i love ribs
what's on them clay pot pork ribs
caramelized with coconut milk over a
garbage slump
huh no
no i don't want that i don't want that
this is
another like
trust fund kid lesbian who wants like
these lesbians just want a place to go
and like
imitate men but badly i saw trust fund
lesbians at coachella
they were really good all dudes
yeah well that was um because mars volta
broke up
and death for cutie broke up
so like half of the guys from each band
got together and and created it you want
to listen to mars vaults
guitar solo like mars volta they found
it the trust fund lesbian
but that's all it is like it's just like
for lesbians to go pretend badly at
being men yeah let's go watch the
liberty play the jazz or whatever we
don't know it's not the jazz what's the
[ __ ]
what's the what's utah's sparks it's
spark versus liberty and we'll have some
beet soup and we'll beat salad
salad and drink craft drinks because
that's what you think when you uh when
you go to a sports bar not hey let me
just get a shot of jameson in a yingling
and what is some stuff you like to throw
in a deep fryer around here how do you
sell beet salad beet salad beet salad do
you want to think you have stomach
cancer tomorrow
uh roast
fresh apple cider vinaigrette
goat cheese toasted hazelnuts and
garnished with cilantro look i'm not
even you guys have a burger here
you know what i mean like i'm a simple
guy man you got any attendees back there
yeah it did fry them up yeah
all of our signature cocktails that
really reminds me of that episode man of
parks and rec when rob lowe's character
was trying to cook a healthy burger and
he gets like turkey burger and he
seasons it and he makes it really like
really nice with it with with with with
uh
with like a sauce that he makes for and
everyone he's like well that's so good
and ron swanson jumps up it's grilled me
put ketchup on it or put ketchup on her
that don't i really don't care and they
eat it and they immediately say it's
better than the [ __ ] fancy one of
course sports bar foods shouldn't be
difficult it should be the easiest food
to make nacho wings burgers quick onion
rings tots things like that
let's go bring those out we're just
going to eat those i don't care i'm
watching the [ __ ] game this the
fanciest thing i want to see is potato
skins
the only adventurous thing should be
like a jalapeno popper or something oh
yeah thank you that's it that's awesome
yeah like a mac and cheese bite or a
dumpling yeah dumplings i've noticed a
lot of bars are like you know what easy
that's the thing it turned it's like i
don't think they thought that early on
but now over the years people are like
turns out those are really easy they're
cheesy so they had to do those but hold
on let's check out this cool bar we're
also uh using carmen ranch beef out of
walawa oregon so she's doing all of our
beef which is pretty great the picnic
tables outside that you see are built by
girls build which is a non-profit
organization
so they fall apart like a bridge at fiu
and they basically teach young girls how
to
build things use power tools measure
things and so you know i reached out to
them you know there's already something
for that it's called youtube it's also
shop class yeah and they were so excited
ultimately i wanted to be a space for
the community can you imagine being a
straight woman walking in that bar by
mistake
you know a place for people to come and
sell it talk about men lesbians are
aggressive
great
this lady this lady looks like
like a pro skateboarder who like became
a heroin addict but like recently kicked
and is now like doing rehab for people
she's like a female brandon novak
she looks like uh
she looks like a uh
like one of the genetic like it's like
you know you know like the tony hawk
generic skateboard character yes like
number three
you're right there's a culture and a
movement that's building that has been
building for years and years and years
to
support our girls and women and
building that fandom i think is really
huge because so many people don't
realize how many fans women's sports
have
actually there's there's a direct metric
that you can use
to find out exactly
how many women sports fans there are and
uh spoiler alert
it's not many
if i remember her hold on
do you remember when tosh did uh
the wnba the wmda
wnba eastern conference finals club me
and my three best friends have been to
every wnba eastern conference final
since the league was started we've
missed commitment ceremonies little
affairs lpga finals parades even that
one day we're allowed at disney world
but it's worth it
that one day we're allowed at disney
world we refuse to miss even one wnba
conference finals i love the stadium
right at tip off we usually just move up
to courtside they even ask marge to sub
in one year 15 is my magic number i want
to see 15 wnba eastern conference finals
or as many as i can until the league
folds
when you use your discover card you
could win a trip
[Laughter]
slightly discover slightly less
embarrassing than capital one
very funny
we see we got any donations